please welcome true
scary more hello happy halloween our set
is already going through some spooky
transformations
i mean look if you can't tell
halloween's one of my favorite holidays
at this point then
i guess you know we haven't been around
um holidays
in our house or should i say the
barrymore house or should i say the
scary more house
well me and my daughters we get really
into it in fact check out
what our entryway looks like right now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh wait i need the wreath
oh yeah that's how we live
and by the way there was not one sound
effect added to that
that's just how it sounds in the room
okay so today i want to give you some of
some tips of my favorite decorating for
your doorstep
your entryway your vestibule however you
live
in a very special designed by drew
scarymore
[Applause]
by the way i just saw that detail with
me in the window i love it in fact i
heard we have a virtual friend that
wants some decorating advice kate
where are you how can i help hey drew
how are you
hi kate i'm real excited what do you
need
so we just moved into our house a few
weeks ago we have boxes everywhere still
my two kids yes as you can see i haven't
gotten around to the halloween
decorations
my kids want to know when the halloween
stuff is getting up we've managed to get
that pumpkin out
and the squirrels have pretty much eaten
all the way through it at this point
ah help me with something simple you
know i have to say
what a beautiful place to start from
congratulations on your new home thank
you so much i'm
so excited listen you're a mom with kids
in a new place it is
a lot to take on right now so i would
love to help
okay so i'm going to start with
suggesting cobwebs
because you can spread them out and you
can kind of find
little places to anchor them and a
little goes a long way you can do a
netting or some traditional cobwebs
and then i really think that it's fun
if you want to go and find some window
decals
they're totally temporary but they add a
really nice silhouette effect
um and you can just buy them online or
in a halloween store
this detail the hands actually i can't
even take credit for that
um i thought we might have been like a
sarah or an alex but i just
love this detail and my daughters just
bought police tape
and so what's really fun about
decorating things with your kids
is let them drive let them be
imaginative and let it become
an activity for all the holidays we do
valentine's day
and easter i mean christmas thanks like
we go
all out so it's really a great way to
busy your kids and say you're in charge
of this
and then also i think for halloween in
particular
as well as thanksgiving pumpkins and
gourds is something that you can go out
just get one each carve them put them
out
that really says halloween to me and
then they also
did this thing here with us our design
team where they put this fun foam in a
cauldron
and then cauldrons can also double as
like
candy you know vessels or
gosh i mean they can double for you know
a fun
after sports game party with some ice
and beverages
there's always a good way to use them
now this is reagan
and hi reagan reagan
i think you scared the children so
reagan was what my daughter olive wanted
for her birthday and then i brought her
home by the way she came home in a hefty
bag which was terrifying
and um the girls decided olive and
frankie that she was too
scary so guess what reagan the girls are
gonna have to grow up a little bit maybe
you'll come back out next year
okay so i happen to think that dolls
definitely add a fun little kick you can
do some
gravestones or some skeleton bones
there's just no way to go wrong
you can have them coming out of your
skirt
and uh the thing that i just really love
about
decorating is my kids and i don't think
i got into any of this kind of
level of spirit before i had them
and they take a lot of pride in it and
they really sometimes
now are saying like we want to do it and
surprise you
so it's really fun to see that kind of
like creativity and independence
um so let them do it and just encourage
it
and um so uh i also want to tell you
that i'm gonna send
all of this except for reagan if that's
okay because i need to scare my girls
with them next year
um and it's olive's birthday present but
everything else i'm sending
right to you right now it's amazing and
my kids are going to go crazy when they
get home from school later
parents you know we're just desperate
for activities for our kids
so this literally eight times a year you
can designate them
to go crazy on the porch in your
beautiful new home
congratulations thank you so much drew
okay thank you so much
thank you kate i love decorating and
design so thank you for this
assignment i hope you like it it's on
its way to you